[Musica]
una storia da raccontare è la storia
delle mie parole e di quello che mi
hanno insegnato da quando per la prima
volta ne ho pronunciata una e quello che
mi hanno insegnato è questo che le
parole hanno un corpo un peso e un costo
sono preziose ma hanno valore solo
quando è dato loro il giusto tempo la
storia delle mie parole inizia quando
sono molto piccola sono con i miei
genitori passeggio in città e stiamo
passando davanti a un cantiere
il cantiere è un luogo che già conosco
perché sono dei libri illustrati di
richards carrey che sfoglio con loro
alla sera c'è proprio un cantiere con
operai e ruspe e tutto il resto
mentre passiamo davanti al cantiere vero
dico è la mia prima parola betoniera non
la prima parola ovviamente e per
esprimere una richiesta un bisogno come
papa un anno ma la prima parola con cui
nomino al mondo per quanto insolita
questa parola fa parte già del mio
destino della mia vita futura da adulta
che vivo per metà da scrittrice metà da
architetto le betoniere davanti formo il
mio vocabolario all'inizio è piena di
parole curiose spesso fuori posto poi
mano a mano che cresca un parole
domestic harle a esprimere ciò che sento
è ciò che penso e soprattutto scopro che
quelle parole si può raccontare così per
i miei 14 anni mi faccio regalare una
macchina da scrivere al negozio scelgo
quella che più dura di ferro inchiostro
quella più pesante di tutti una olivetti
lettera 35 me la porta a casa da sola
non voglio che nessuno mi aiuti
e una volta arrivato a casa voglio
scoprire quanto pesano le parole allora
sago sulla bilancia prima col olivetti
in braccio presenza che ci sono cinque
chili e mezzo di differenza
da quel giorno in avanti
per me le parole hanno quel peso 5 chili
e mezzo
poco più tardi al liceo classico studio
il teatro greco e quindi o che fare con
le parole antiche che hanno questo
potere enorme di agire creare la scena
non ci sono nemmeno gli attori a
recitarle ci sono soltanto i versi
quell'ora andare a capo e parlare da un
per sparata stare da un personaggio
all'altro ma quelle parole bastano per
costruire le mura di tebe si spostano
andate a volte accarezza una volte mi
prendono a schiaffi
le parole di sofocle bastano a farmi
commuovere per il destino di antigone
nel volto di quella ragazzina ribelle ha
quasi dopo quasi tremila anni
riconosco qualcosa di me le parole
quindi hanno un corpo un peso e un volto
e hanno un costo soprattutto quando si
tratta di necrologi con mia madre ne
scriviamo parecchie li scriviamo per gli
anniversari dei suoi genitori a volte
anche dei suoi nonni
questa cosa per me sembra realtà una
cosa triste ma per me lo ricordo felice
mia madre mi insegna in queste occasioni
a sintetizzare infatti dobbiamo riuscire
a fare stare in poche parole in poche
righe tutto quello che ci sta a cuore e
quindi in una riga devono trovare spazio
all'amore la nostalgia al dolore e
quello che era caro al defunto invitano
per onorarlo e non è una cosa facile
purtroppo se citiamo il verso di una
canzone o della poesia
dobbiamo cedere ai grassetti che come si
sa negli annunci grassetti costano il
doppio
la storia delle mie parole ci insegna
quindi che hanno un peso hanno un corpo
e hanno un costo e quando li usiamo
dovremmo riconoscere tutto questo o
almeno prestare i loro l'attenzione che
merita
no non sono mai casuali in fondo le
parole sono delle scelte
ciascuno di noi ha le sue parole
preferite
io prediligo le parole accoglienti
quelle più rotonde delle altre magari
cave all'interno parole come ciotola
canoa temperamatite platea orca botte
fratello ping pong uovo alla coque nei
miei due mestieri l'architetta la
scrittrice do molta importanza la scelta
della materia prima
mi sono chiesta spesso quale connessione
ci sia tra architettura e scrittura
scrivere in fondo è l'arte di usare le
parole usate da secoli e ma in modo
sempre nuovo è un'eredità e anche
costruire lo è come succede in giappone
dove c'è un tempio il tempio di isee
quindi vent'anni viene demolito e
ricostruito
perché i giovani imparino come si fa i
materiali sono quindi sempre gli stessi
ma sono le mani che costruiscono che
cambiano e quindi se pensiamo alle
parole alle pietre come un'eredità
allora a scrivere costruire sono un po
allo stesso mestiere e poi le parole
scritte rimangono infatti sono qui con
me davanti a me ben stampate come per
gli appuntamenti importanti le ho
rilette un po di volte adesso lo sto
leggendo a voi e prima di dirle
trattengo un istante dentro di me nella
mia testa vi confermo come si conferma
un indirizzo quando qualcuno ti viene a
trovare a casa per la prima volta a vito
qui le mie parole sono la mia casa
averne cura e quindi avere cura del mio
spazio più intimo
penso anche alle mie parole più
sfortunate quelle che abbandono nei
messaggi nei commenti che sono costrette
a convivere con
le icone appariscenti le faccette che
piangono disperatamente ridono anche pa
pelle e tutte le volte mi pento penso
che ho parlato di fretta e in modo
disattento
perché se la comunicazione si riducesse
a questo bene mi interessa sapete cosa
vi dico
per andare veloce curri stando zitto ma
per andare lontano
scegli le parole giuste le parole giuste
ci invitano a procedere
ma lentamente perché alle parole va dato
il tempo di portarci lontano e anche
riposo in questa febbre della
comunicazione è bene lasciare che le
parole ogni tanto riposino e noi con
loro
questo si chiama silenzio la storia
delle mie parole comprende anche
moltissimi silenzi in cui non dire o
scrivere niente in cui magari godersi la
voce di qualcun altro o condividere lo
stesso silenzio e nel silenzio che le
parole si rigenerano se nella storia
dell'uomo non ci fossero stati ampi
momenti di grande silenzio le parole ci
sarebbero arrivate consumate munch e
inutilizzabili forse invece eccole qui
sempre nuove averne ancora faticoso ma
vale lo sforzo perché se ho già usate
con il giusto tempo le parole ci tengono
nel tempo sono come un rimedio a piccole
dosi per stare nel presente e momenti
molto propizi come quello della
scrittura o del cantiere in cui gration
nuovo tempio fanno ancora di più ti
riportano indietro all'inizio di tutto
io ogni volta che scrivo qualcosa di
nuovo ritorno al mio essere principiante
al principio lì a rotolo nastro
dimentico tutte quelle parole che dava
ormai per acquisite per scontate che mi
facevano sentire sicura di me perché non
voglio essere sicura voglio la
possibilità di non sapere quello che
accadrà
voglio provare stupore
voglio di nuovo essere quella bambina di
18 mesi che con estrema serietà dice
betoniera il mondo nominato finalmente
dalla mia voce accade grazie
[Musica]